[Music]
I think of trust and hope as being
really quite closely related and
oftentimes we trust we trust without
really having to worry too much about
whether the person we're trusting is
able to do what we're trusting them with
maybe they're very reliable type and you
know we've trusted them in the past with
this sort of thing and we don't really
we're not too worried about their
capacity for living up to that trust but
very often we're having to trust under
conditions where a little more uncertain
or where we think there's some sort of
as it were almost moral obligations
certainly it can be a sort of parental
obligation to trust for example our
children when we think maybe they're not
fully reliable yet and they may well
disappoint us but it's certainly
important part of being you know raising
those children to understand that they
are going to be asked to do things they
are going to be relied on various ways
it's a it's a way of allowing them to
develop those capacities to be
responsive to trust which is a very
important feature of human social life
and there I think we do need to energize
our trust with our own capacity to hope
where that means something very
particular for me that is to say when we
hope for things we are always facing the
fact that we could be disappointed and
we're facing that disappointment sort of
in a clear-eyed way that is if we're
hoping well and we're saying you know I
understand what the stakes are here but
I think this is an important thing to do
and it's important to regulate my own
anxiety about this so I use my hope to
put certain worries offline as a word to
just not focus on them to focus instead
on what could be
under the right sort of conditions and
giving whatever support is necessary to
make that come about but of course I
have to as a hope or realize that I
could be disappointed and also therefore
that I have the kind of capacity to
recover from disappointment that's a
very important part of hoping well
[Music]